let's run off with Travis Travis Travis
fellow is your microphone working okay
yeah perfect
so a world it's immersive like this a
world you know Azeroth versus something
like Vikings like what are the two
worlds compare how do you is it help as
an actor to take undertake something of
this scale well firstly I'd like to say
how gorgeous beautiful is Paula Patton
Ruth and especially Dominic Cooper look
today but uh know also uh lucky to have
the boss man here Duncan in charge he
put us in this amazing world of you know
magical characters and and it was such a
great experience in a new one for me
I've never done the motion capture stuff
and it's amazing to see that this is
what I was actually looking at have you
not seen anything from my end I would
say no it's amazing I saw Bruce Lee
broomsticks with foam on the end yeah it
looks good work well yeah because I mean
as an actor when you come in and it just
looks like oh we're gonna find with Foam
swords in front of a green thing and
then you're just trusting you're gonna
do something cool with this right
we've got Tiger keval walking around in
pajamas response on him so uh it's it
looks amazing right I'm very impressed
Paula what can you tell us about Corona
gosh well it's probably the greatest
challenge I had as an actress because
she's half human half art um she comes
from this world a drain or she is slave
of glue ban and she is uh put to the
test in the world that she lives in and
then she finds herself in Azeroth but
most of the humans and her life is
changed and she never really fixed it in
either world she sort of has one foot in
each and
and you know you when you're an actress
you might want to find research but you
don't know how to research how to play
an orc have to figure it out so I was
scared to death
it was the scariest thing I've ever
undertaken
but I'm so glad I did it I loved it was
amazing work with Duncan and and it's
quite unreal and surreal to see this
world right now
well she's written she's such a strong
character in such a great character I
mean everyone by the way Ben Foster's
performance as medivh is so fantastic
you were so wonderful absolutely Ben I
notice a second ago you were just
dumping water on Toby that was uh pardon
and so you tumble in a water on Toby he
was including my crunch yeah so hot yeah
I think just in the interest of time
because I do believe you brought some
footage that we're gonna be able to show
some people I'd love to just sort of go
down one at a time because there's so
many people on the panel and maybe just
say one thing about your character or
one thing that you really loved about
this experience as a whole started with
you Ben who here is familiar with the
game World of Warcraft yeah so who
doesn't want to be a wizard so that's
that was my hook that the experience was
was uh was a thrill getting to work with
Duncan who have you guys seen moon his
film is risk with God this is a man with
a very specific vision he huh and he
brought that vision to a beloved game
and he elevated that game to a film and
getting the opportunity to play with his
gas and his crew with this with this
material from Blizzard and legendary is
uh it's a once-in-a-lifetime there are
you tell me yeah I mean yeah difficult
to follow that because it's true it's
all true but I'm I played Durotan he's a
chieftain of the Frostwolf clan this is
my right-hand man
I missed the king out he's a human and I
know is on my life my right-hand man but
I didn't serve this and that's about
Derek did you uh did you feel like did
you feel like the Alliance had a little
bit easier in this film no we had it
really tough we had to wear those
incredibly heavy outfits every day we
had it so easy oh yeah very nice ethical
pajamas every day and little sense
stuxnet foreheads and danced around
every day we Wed sweaty wigs and very
heavy armor I couldn't even lift up my
sword I was pathetic never seen such a
big sword that's good I swear I was
gonna be a kid that's gonna be the quote
from the panel I've never seen such a
big sword or Pratt it gets bigger I mean
that really is
go on uh it really is sort of the
subtext for craft the biggest sword
wrought Rob Kazinsky by the way I mean I
know we talked about this a lot in
psychic Blizzcon with you
Kaczynski is a legitimate like this this
man is the soul of Warcraft it has been
in his life and his world for thousands
of hours before this movie I managed to
get myself I kind of I'm up to the maybe
600 days played now and yeah yeah so
basically I didn't wanna time to do that
so get so ripped but there was a time
when I wasn't in the Warcraft movie and
in that time I was unemployed for a lot
of that time I spent it eating cake and
playing Warcraft and I got honest like
cuz we're that much Warcraft and being
that into the world is really I mean I
lost a relationship and really good one
too I lost I lost self-esteem but it
wouldn't be really really sad and
pathetic if I wasn't doing this movie
which is totally made it okay yeah well
this movie comes down you could email
that girl from the relation to be like
see this was for a thing she left me
because of Warcraft and I'm now I'm like
well who won this round yeah two and
research all those years and for the
Horde
I and also I get to play with and I know
I'm biased and it sounds rubbish but
this is I mean especially with fostering
Carol here I think this is the most
talented young cast I've ever seen
assembled in a movie and it has been a
privilege
apart from Toby Kebbell to work for
these people every single day they've
made a great movie and I'm not just
saying that I mean I I know that I'm a
gamer and I know what I'm expecting is
what you're expecting from this thing
and I promise you Duncan Jones has made
the movie that we wanted to see
excellent I'll stand where up there Ted
[ __ ] tell us anything you can tell us
about your experience what was your
favorite thing I mean I think getting
and getting a chance to work with Duncan
and this cats just to reiterate what Rob
said was a major privilege and uh yeah
it was a total trip I mean I think the
fact that it's not a cut and dry good
versus evil story this is a story about
two heroes basically like on a collision
course it made it unique in the arc and
that was really attractive to me and uh
it was just it's a total trip it was
amazing great experience I mean it looks
it looks a bit hard to recognize some of
the some of the orcs because you I mean
it doesn't look like CG and you can
barely when people start talking like
Clancy Brown I didn't realize it was
Clancy at first tonight cause like
that's placement you can kind of make
out his face and it was what was the
motion capture experience like for you
classic mood um we repent and to walk
answer best answer all day
I look out here at this crowd and all I
see is fuel for the film Ruth what can
you tell us about I said what do you
tell us about about about lady Tarija
the just your experience in the audience
what could you tell well behind every
great man there's a great woman and
she's a very dignified lady who I'm uh
loves her land and she's she's just a
certain steel
stealing's to her and Anna she's not
unit she knows what she's doing and
she's she knows they're fighting for
right and it was such a pleasure to work
on this film and work with Duncan and
this misfit cast yeah I just can't wait
to see it well in a minute you're gonna
see a little bit of it Daniel tell us
anything about cool down and and just
and also the responsibilities that may
be of oh this is the character that's
very personal to people because I'm like
of translating a book into a film you
know people really connect it like a
game especially game like Warcraft is so
much a part of who you are you bond to
it so how do you feel
taking of this feel like a lot of
responsibility yeah I mean golden is a
is a iconic character of the game and
it's a it's a daunting task because
there's so many people have their own
version of who these characters are from
playing the game and I know that because
and also to thank my wife because she
plays the game and she played for many
many years and she's actually the reason
why I did
I mean of course I did it for Duncan and
this amazing cast and all that but
really is to get my 1 get in my wife's
good uh Chris because she's played the
game for many many years I watched her
play for many many years on the side and
uh what eventually the story to tell
when I when I got the audition for this
I would actually was meant to take a
year off as my wife just had a baby we
were gonna spend time with the baby and
I found out about this audition I went I
told her I said honey uh you know I
promised I'd take a year off but this
audition coming up and she goes you
promised me you wouldn't work and I said
but it's work out and she goes you have
to [ __ ] do it and so that was an easy
question and I've been here hero ever
since so I think I gained more out of
this and most people did excellent
so before I'm about to show you what I'm
about to show you
please do not real do not take video of
this do not try to be sneaky please
respect respect the Comic Con code you
guys waited this is just for you this is
very special no one's seen this before
okay so put your devices down and enjoy
things with your eyes like nature
intended and ladies and gentlemen please
I am so happy to present to you some
footage from Warcraft when a gentleman
that is more crap please help me huge
round of applause for Duncan Jones and
the cast of Warcraft
you
you